ramas money closes in on the sentence as
Trump dominates in GOP Paul the hill
former president Trump leads the GOP
Primary uh field with 49 support
according to a recent poll by Echelon
insights Florida Governor Ron descent as
follows in second place with 16 while
biotech entrepreneur Vivek ramaswan is
behind them with 10 ramas money has been
a two percentage Point increase in
support since a previous poll conducted
in May where he had eight percent in
contrast DeSantis has experienced a
three percentage drop since May when he
guarded 19 points Congress concerns with
the sentences viability as a candidate
has emerged particularly following a
glitchy Twitter spaces I'm not worried
about that one right there his recent
criticism of trump post
support for LGBT community has drawn
backlash from GOP groups such as Log
Cabin Republicans those things I'm not
concerned about but the part is vivec
okay why why do you think vivec is
getting this surge what do you think is
getting Kim to get people to say man I
kind of like this guy I kind of like
what he has to say he's not scared to
open his mouth Pat like just yesterday I
think it was yesterday some uh lady in
the back uh he was doing some some talk
in like a like not an auditorium like an
open area and she's like Town Hall she's
like it's my body my choice I have a kid
and it was like an exchange where the
lady was leaving he's like no no come
back here let's have a conversation she
came to the stage she started crying
he's having but I think he's not scared
to talk he's not scared to voice the
pain and Pat marketing he's not saying
no
and he's smart as hell and he's probably
one of the most efficient and effective
communicators that's running right now
regardless of whether you like him or
not he has his hand on the pulse of
cultural issues which would have been
desantis's I guess his trump card all
right I mean he's someone who's actually
not just talking about the culture War
he's actively fighting it but he doesn't
do a good job articulating it in the
same way that Vivek does I mean he he's
he's been on the daily wire before he
even announced he is very very he knows
what the average voter cares about and I
think if we look at what happened in
Virginia with Glenn junking yankin I
mean this isn't just oh culture War
stuff it doesn't matter no these issues
they're getting people out and they're
getting especially Suburban moms to vote
so I think he's really playing his cards
right just overall yeah I I love the way
he communicates I love the way how
respectful he is I love the way he
pushes back but more importantly I love
how hard he's working he's everywhere
you know what's one of the most
intimidating things to do to your
competitors I love doing this in the
insurance space or any kind of business
when we were first coming up in our
podcast said small YouTube channel we
had like 50 000 Subs okay value payment
we got four and a half million not the
time was fifty thousand subs and I'm in
Dallas who the hell wants to interview
in Dallas nobody wants to go to freaking
Dallas the only people that are in
Dallas are the conservatives the only
person I had was the blaze I had nobody
else I want to interview everybody but
everyone's in that everyone's in La
Miami all this stuff you know what we
did we'd go to New York I'd rent a hotel
room and I would do six seven eight
interviews in two days back to back to
back to back so I got notes like this
next guest next guest next guest next
guest next guest would go to Miami seven
interviews we'd go to La 12 interviews
and then we would have enough interviews
over the next two three four weeks while
I'm running a company while we're having
baby after baby after baby while I'm
going National visiting office all this
stuff is happening
it's so intimidating to see vivec
everywhere it's as if he's got triplets
it's him and two other brothers yeah one
minute this year next minute he says how
the hell are you everywhere that is so
draining to your enemy to your
competitors to say yeah I'm not willing
to do this unless if you're willing to
come to Tallahassee to interview me I'm
not going anywhere yeah you're going to
lose to God like this yeah you don't
lose to a guy like this that's willing
to go everywhere and anywhere to talk to
anybody he's gaining that kind of
respect by the way if you would like to
see us do a live podcast
at 59.90 live with vivec I'm talking
town hall where you can ask him
questions if you would like to do that
text award podcast to
310-340-1132-310-340-1132 text award
podcast to that number we are thinking
about who to have next I'm doing a July
20th live podcast those tickets that
have already sold out but the next one
we're doing we're talking to potentially
many different camps if you'd like to
see a live podcast with Vivek again text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]